j'ai cru que vous voulez que je viens de
pompes zigouiller
qu'est-ce qui me prouve que je vais pas
recommencer
c'est vous que je m'entends dire qu'on
fait parce que depuis 25 années
tous m'ont dit mais c'était quoi c'est
quoi la vue de ceux ci pour qu'il fasse
un truc pareil
je sais que j'ai fait une grosse
connerie tu sens coupable
bah oui ces chiens gémir comme ça la
tamise gonzesses taggage chance d'avoir
match que moi je peux plus avoir mal
tourner le jeu continue oui mais qu'est
ce qu'ils me prouvent que c'est pas des
conneries tout ça mais pourquoi voulez
vous raconte des conneries vous croyez
que c'est venu ici pourquoi vous êtes
une faute de la nature une erreur
nouveaux comptes relève la tête on dit
[Musique]
c'est quoi ce truc
non non non et puis qu'est ce qu'on
attend des commandes
pourquoi j'ai voulu qu'on se rend compte
là y'a quoi là dedans y'a quoi la charia
moi aussi j'aurais pu devenir un monstre
un mois
[Musique]